C4! C4, baby!
Put some stuff right there...put one more right there... there... one more there.
Right there. Yeah, that's good.
C'mon.
Someone...
Someone's gonna go in this house. Whether they like it or not! Come on... come on...
Come on. You, can you can do it.
Kay...
Shenanigans are happening!
Ooh... oh.. ooh...
OOP!
I'm starting to think no one's gonna come to my birthday party, but I got the candle! Right here!
Anybody?!
Hmm -  still having a birthday party! Anybody that.. wants to come by...
Mmm
Well still in the circle technically!
Top ten and I've been in the same goddamn building this whole time waiting for people to come to my goddamn birthday party. That's just rude!
That's weird... Top five and I'm just sitting here, I've been sitting here this whole goddamn game.
Ah...Fuck of course! I'm not gonna let it go down like this...
I'm not gonna let it go down like this!
I'm top three, and I've been sitting in a fucking house for the whole goddamn game...
Someone is getting blown up with these explosives.
OH my god, it's just me and another dude!
OH NO! It's just me and them!
Ah, but-
Such a shit thing to do-o! I didn't ask for this. I just wanted to blow someone up!
I just wanted to blow someone up. I've said that someone is gonna get blown up by this C4!
There's only two people left in the game
Everyone knows what I have to do! I go down of my own accord!!!
{ And this, ladies and gentlemen, was the sacrifice that brave Mark Edward Fishbach did to save his audience from dying from boredom... we thank you, Markimoo... We'll remember you... }
Uh.. I think they're just stuck in disbelief... what the fuck just happened? { ughgggrgrgr that's what everyone at home would like to know? ( FNAF 3 MARKIMOO REFERENCE ) }
And frankly I don't blame them!!